what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future okay so one of the
character is that I constantly get a
request on is onslaught people are like
Rob just do anything about awesome I'll
even care what it is just tell us what
his powers are how spells just talk
about onslaught okay so I figured we do
the origin of onslaught but here's a
kicker the origin of onslaught is not
like a comic you can't go to like the
store or you can't go to comixology and
you can't buy like the origin of
onslaught it'd be cool if you could but
you can't instead on slots creation his
origin story is part and parcel or I
guess it's just as much a comic book
origin as it is what Marvel does instead
of rebooting what I mean by this is like
DC reboots right DC does like a hard
reboot where they're like everything
before this point is canceled everything
this comes out now is the new continuity
so crisis on Infinite Earths wiped out
the multiverse created a singular
universe zero hour crisis of time blink
that universe head of existence and
brought it back which created continuity
issues Infinite Crisis recreated the
multiverse and Final Crisis made the
superheroes aware of the fact of the
multiverse was back
that's DC's reboost new vg2 wiped
everything out and started all over
again
DC rebirth brought some of the pre new
52 stuff back Marvel doesn't do that
Marvel is just like let's reinvigorate
characters let's reimagine them let's
kind of cancel them you know and then
bring them back in a different way
now for those of the guys who have seen
my videos or who have heard my spiels on
the comic bust of the 90s bear with me
for a second because every video
somebody's first video so let's say that
it's like 1916 and you own a copy of DC
showcase number four which is the first
appears of Barry Allen ever in the
history of comic books now if it's like
1960 the only choice you'd really have
is to go to your local comic book store
say hey I want to sell this how much is
it worth and you're literally just left
to the behest of whatever that store
owner says your comic might be worth a
thousand dollars but he's like I'll give
you a hundred bucks for it any of you
take a hundred bucks you take nothing
and that's it in the 1970s we got a book
called the Overstreet buyer's guide
which was like no no no no here's how
much your comic is worth depending on
the quality whether or not it's in
really good condition depending on how
rare it is how many people have that the
contents of the comic so Superman
battling or I guess really Superman and
Batman ever fought but like Superman and
Batman fighting alongside each other is
not worth nearly as much is like the
first
here is of Hal Jordan that was worth a
ton of money the first appearance of
spider-man amazing fantasy number 15
here was the kicker people who had no
reason who never would have picked up a
comment but before we're going through
this Overstreet's buyer's guide and they
were like wow if I buy this comic where
Gwen Stacy died in 1971 and I hold it
for 20 years it's gonna be worth a ton
of money I never read comics I have no
reason to but I can put my kids through
college in 20 years if I hold on to this
well the problem is that suddenly
everybody was doing that and because
everybody was buying comics there was
now a market to open up color bookstores
so everybody was opening up comic book
stores the issue with this is that it's
like diamonds if you're walking down the
road one day and you find a red diamond
and it's never been seen before that red
diamond is worth a ton of money but then
if somebody's hiking through the woods
or hiking through a cave and they find a
wall that's just filled with millions of
red diamonds
well then suddenly your red diamond is
virtually worthless and that's exactly
what happened people were going and
buying multiple issues of comic books
they were buying a ton of comic books
coming book creators were just creating
a ton of color books so now this death
of Gwen Stacy the first appearance of
Barry Allen the death of Superman
Batman's back being broken in nightfall
these comics were virtually worthless
and so because of that people stopped
buying comics which meant that now
coming the publishers were almost
completely out of money now DC was
better off than Marvel because DC had
already been bought by Warner Brothers
so they had corporate backing but for
Marvel they were like if we don't sell
comics we go bankrupt that's why they
sold off the rights to like spider-man
the x-men Fantastic Four Blade that's
why they sold those movie rights to Fox
Sony so on and so forth because they
needed the money now at the same time
despite the fact that DC had corporate
backing they still had to get their
ducks in order Marvel was really more
pressed so they had like trim the fat
they had to sit down and say okay what
colics can we keep what comics can we
cancel we can't get rid of the Avengers
we can't get rid of the Fantastic Four
those are cornerstones if it came out
that we'd cancel The Avengers of the
Fantastic Four well then people would
just give up on us forever the x-men
were at an all-time high in popularity
because of Chris Claremont run because
x-men vol 2 issue number one had been
launched here yet Chris Claremont Jim
Lee the comic just scream 1990s and so
because of that the x-men weren't gonna
sell at least it was believed they were
gonna sell forever so Marvel just kept
printing those but when they sat down
and said as they said okay we have to
reinvigorate the Fantastic Four and the
Avengers and a handful of others we've
got to change them up we've got to make
them more interesting but we can't just
do that all of a sudden we've got a
our way into it so what Marvel did is
they said and they said okay let's
create a villain that basically wipes
out the universe released it seems like
he's gonna wipe out the universe but
he's not going to instead we're
basically gonna have him defeated but in
the process we're gonna kind of but not
really kill off the Avengers and the
Fantastic Four so that's why we got
onslaught now in terms of his origin
story and comic books it's actually
short and is pretty straightforward what
had happened was when Chris Claremont
left the title Gimli Scot Liddell Fabian
de Caesar
they had basically gotten together and
they said okay let's go ahead and
reinvigorate things let's launch a story
called fatal attractions and everything
had been leading up to this I mean it
was like the entire history of the x-men
had led up to this point but there are a
couple things that went into it so first
and foremost Charles Xavier Charles
Xavier z-- dream of a peaceful
coexistence between humans of mutants
was the basis behind his foundation of
the x-men it had always been that way
that was his core belief he was the
Martin Luther King jr. of Marvel Comics
I'm 100% serious look it up like that's
literally what he was made to be Stan
Lee and Jack Kirby had talked about that
he was modeled after Martin Luther King
so on the other side you had magneto and
magneto again according to Stan Lee and
Jack Kirby was written to be the Malcolm
X of the Marvel Universe
he believed in mutant rights but he was
willing to take a more extreme approach
to pull that off now over the course of
Chris Claremont Run Chris Claremont
actually reworked magneto to where he
was more along the lines of a good guy
than a bad guy the problem with that is
people loved bad guy magneto it was cool
to see him try to be a good guy it was
cool to see him leave the x-men for a
while but when x-men vol 2 was launched
when Scott Liddell came on board when
Chris Claremont left magneto was
basically taken back to his roots to
being a bad guy but what we also saw was
the introduction of this group called
the acolytes and the acolytes were like
Magneto's own horsemen so to speak where
they basically carried out his own wants
his own desires they worked on his
behalf they were extremists they were
radicals but this eventually led to a
conflict where magneto was formed
asteroid em and the x-men had travelled
to asteroid ham and battle magneto now
during this conflict that took place
magneto and his anger and in his wrath
had basically become fed up with the
x-men he said enough is enough I'm tired
of you guys getting in the way I'm tired
of the guys causing problems all you do
is screw stuff up you guys are like
roaches that I can't kill and so he
lashed out at Wolverine and when he did
he ripped the adamantium out of his body
now this was one of the most badass
moments in the history of comic books I
mean it's the coolest thing wolf rage
was like oh how like he's screaming and
the adamantium is being yanked out it's
one of the most iconic moments and comic
books I mean you show that to anybody
they're like yeah that's when Wolverines
does that a man team ripped out right
like why do you don't know the story
they don't know what was going on at the
time it's just they recognized that
moment because I so iconic but this
basically set the stage for the
introduction of Moore's Law because what
happened is Charles Xavier had freaked
he had said look this is enough you know
you've done enough violence you
destroyed enough things you wiped out
the electrical systems of the earth for
time humanity we literally had to
rebuild you've constantly been a thorn
on the side of everybody you've made
every mutant look bad everywhere you've
basically created this viewpoint that
all mutants are terrorists you gotta go
and so he basically just like shut down
the mind of magneto but what Scott
Liddell Gimli amphibian two-season
established was that Xavier didn't
really shut down the mind of magneto so
much as he took Magneto's mind into his
own and basically kept it dormant but in
the background of Charles Xavier zone
brain without him realizing it really in
a subconscious the hatred that magneto
had for Humanity merged with Charles
Xavier frustration with humanity and the
reason for this is because over the
course of Scotland's run on the x-men
Aurelius part of Chris Claremont Sauron
dating all the way back to the
introduction of the superhuman
Registration Act toying with the notion
of the Days of Future past came into
existence mutants were being killed and
Charles Xavier constantly felt helpless
of the fact that he couldn't save a lot
of those movies and so because of that
Xavier was becoming more and more
frustrated because the question is why
can't humanity just hope with mutants
like what's so wrong with mutants that
humanity just can't cope with him and so
this frustration mingled with Xavier
hatred and onslaught was born the kicker
about this was that onslaught was really
just dormant for ever and ever and ever
he was constantly in the background but
every once in a while he would crop up
like Xavier would give the x-men some
erroneous instructions like go kill that
villain somewhere in the x1 would just
kind of be like I mean I don't know
about that Xavier that's that's pretty
extreme and telling us to go kill people
I don't know how I feel about that but
it was just every once in a while like
this really dark element of it would
crop up and it would beg the question is
this really Charles Xavier talking or is
there something else going on here but
again because of the fact that it was
part and parcel to the onslaught saga
the origin of masada releases first at
full on up here
came when he basically appeared to Jean
Grae and this was really what he began
changing everything because on slots
entire minds that was really more of
less wage as much of a psychic war as a
physical war because again you know with
him having the mind of Charles Xavier he
basically knew how to take out each one
of the x-men on a psychological
standpoint how to mess with their minds
but again at this point we're starting
to getting into the onslaught saga as
opposed to just kind of focusing on his
origin but that's really an I mean the
origin is pre straightforward is not
really really complicated it's just
rooted in the idea that Xavier is
frustration with humanity and Magneto's
hatred with humanity merged it to a
singular being and then after that
onslaught was like we got a grab
Cyclopes the key to me being able to
just recreate everything in existence
and it created a really really cool
story because unlike apocalypse he gets
involved in the watchers like man thing
he's about to pop off like Jean Grey
removes Bruce Banner from the mind of
the Incredible Hulk of the Incredible
Hulk rages it's a super cool story
fortunately it's only like four volumes
I think so I might cover that over the
course of the next few weeks I don't
know but despite that that's pretty much
the origin of our lot it's pretty
straightforward again it's not super
complicated super wild to grasp but if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you hit the subscribe button to become
part of the robb cornfield this was cool
make sure you drop a like and leave a
comment down below let me know what you
think about onslaught because he is a
man he's uh he's a beast I mean
onslaught is a wrecking machine but he
literally went through and just crushed
everybody the Avengers the Fantastic
Four the x-men I mean just everybody got
wrecked in the face of onslaught in the
end it took the Incredible Hulk punching
a hole through his armor for everybody
to defeat him it was like be incredible
hulk saves the Marvel Universe it was
super cool it was really cool when it
first came out but yeah so we're gonna
go ahead and bring this video to an end
and I will catch you all later peace
[Music]